Speaker 1: I'm going to show you an incredible,
incredible video in which the mother of a fallen
Capitol riot officer refuses to shake Mitch
McConnell's hand. And so do others. And they
walk right by. It's truly incredible stuff to
see. As Newsweek reports, the mother of a fallen
Capitol police officer refused to shake the hands
of two Republican lawmakers during yesterday's
Congressional Gold Medal ceremony honoring the
officers who defended the Capitol during the
January six riot. Gladys Sicknick, the mother of
Brian Sicknick, that was the U.S. Capitol officer
who died of a stroke following the riot, did not
accept a handshake offered by Mitch McConnell and
by Representative Kevin McCarthy. They, of course,
were part of the movement that led to the riots.
We have the video here. And it is it's really
something. I'm going to play it. And as you will
see, there are individuals here who first greet
Chuck Schumer and then they continue on by. You
see that it is Schumer and then it is McConnell
and then it is McCarthy. And you see Mitch
McConnell stick out his hand and then you see
people just walk by. You see people walk by. There
is another there is Gladys Sicknick. She walks
by and then they just continue to walk by. And
Mitch McConnell standing there he is really you
know, they say Joe Biden shook hands with the air.
There is applause. It is really Mitch McConnell.
They are shaking hands with the air. Now,
we actually heard from Brian's
brother, Ken Sicknick, who was asked,
what was that about? Why didn't you shake hands?
And he says, well, it's pretty self-evident,
but I'll tell you anyway, take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Self-explanatory. But, you know,
they came out right away and condemned
what happened on January 16th. And
whatever poll that Trump has on them, the facts,
nothing. They would admit to wrongdoing, not
necessarily them themselves or of Trump over the
rioters. I mean, people even like Louie Gohmert,
who presented an American flag that was flown over
the Capitol from January 6th. Right. And told them
they were okay. It's disgusting. And now it takes
away everything my brother has done, takes away my
talk about the heroism my brother showed.
Speaker 2: You know,
you don't think you don't think they
deserved a handshake in this context? No. No.
Speaker 1: What are you even saying
by shaking their hands? Like what?
It really. It actually doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 4: Because I'm Bush Cheney. They have
no idea what integrity they can stand up with,
right or wrong. It's no good party 45. Let's
give up a political career doing what is right
and try to find the solution. She's the one real
hope. Covering the whole thing. That they can show
integrity or they can show you actually care about
the process involved, about everything that goes
on. And these guys are heroes standing out in
front of it. We're going to do it on Tuesday.
Speaker 1: Hard to argue against what he's
saying. And this entire January six riot fiasco,
which now is going on nearly two years, I mean,
we're getting closer to the two year anniversary
of the riots. It feels like it was just yesterday.
It has been emblematic of the absolute worst of
the Republican Party. It's been emblematic of we
just say stuff, but we don't really have values.
We stand by such as we are for law and order
until hundreds of their supporters rioted,
committing various crimes on January six,
2021. All of a sudden they're defending
those people. We are for backing the blue
and supporting law enforcement until all of a
sudden the targets of their followers were Capitol
Police. And of course, as we know with the FBI,
that's also been a popular target as well. Every
single one of these stated principles and values
that they hold dear and they love to talk about,
here are our principles. And they we can
know the Constitution well. They want the
Constitution thrown out. That was part of what
the riots were for. At the end of the day,
whether overtly or implicitly, they wanted the
person who won based on the process outlined
by the Constitution, to not get the office that
they won. And they wanted the guy that lost Donald
Trump to be the president. But we care about the
Constitution. Well, not when it's inconvenient,
but we support law enforcement. Well, not when
it's inconvenient. We support law and order,
not when it's inconvenient. And then now all
of a sudden, they say, oh, pretrial detention,
the conditions these rioters are being held that
are unfair. Well, we've been talking about that
for over a decade on the program. And you insist,
oh, listen, if you get charged with a crime,
it's probably because you're guilty and you
deserve whatever conditions there are and
you're too dangerous to be let out on pretrial.
You have to be held in pretrial detention.
Endless, endless. And now this is the outcome. And
fortunately or unfortunately or whatever, it's a
lesson that they are learning, but that they're
not really appearing to learn. Anything from